in this city all men are not created  equal  for centuries my countrymen have  suffered under the oppression of an  ignorant and decadent aristocracy the  common people cry out for food for  liberty for justice but they shall have  no justice without someone to fight in  their name  [Applause]  so I will weigh my silent move in the  shadows the time has come for revolution  for those to unite and make history  make history Assassin's Creed unity  pre-order now for two bonus offers the  guillotines spend a win game get a  chance to win prizes every Friday and  the explosive chemical revolution  mission pre-order now available October  28th  [Music]